[Music]
this maxim photo shoot that you did
promoting this movie this is an
incredible photo
now i'm guessing that's a fellow in a
gorilla costume it is indeed yeah who's
in that costume that is a very good
question isn't it
uh cause that's a very intimate thing
and i just i saw that photo and my being
me i'm thinking how do you get to be the
gorilla guy
i'm sorry that's pervy but you do think
that
well you know actually we were kind of
wondering who it was a great concept and
i got to set that day and i was like ah
this is gonna be so much fun and then
you go wow
but so who is actually gonna be in the
suit and so some poor guy or guy i don't
know if he's poor guy
poor guy if i have to i will
i don't want to but if i have to
it was one of the lighting guys like one
of the ladies so they just pointed at
someone and said you're the right size
getting in it and you know i say poor
guy because he literally couldn't
breathe so i was you know and he was so
he was okay he was so respected
he wouldn't like put his hand he was
literally like this and kind of shaking
him like just put them on like otherwise
the world is gonna see them when they
take the picture like cover my nipples
please and he's like okay
and it's a tough job market out there
they say there are no good jobs left in
america
[Applause]